xtreamer müsste man sein jeden tag zu
hause ein paar stündchen computerspiele
spielen oder mit seinen zuschauern und
lustige youtube videos schauen dabei
millionen kassieren und dort leben wo
andere urlaub machen aber wie ist das
eigentlich wirklich täglich vor
dutzenden menschen unterhaltsam sein zu
müssen wie schnell wir meinen stream
wachsen und wie viel geld werde ich
dabei verdienen ich finds heraus und
arbeitet ab sofort acht stunden täglich
als vollzeit riemer nachdem klassisches
on demand video streaming ca 2010 mit
youtube seinen durchbruch feiern konnte
dauerte es circa drei jahre bis das live
stream zuerst auftritt und dann auch auf
youtube ein breites publikum fand aber
wie können streamer mit nur 1000
zuschauern überhaupt davon leben wenn
auf youtube 1000 klicks doch höchstens
ein bis zwei euro bringen und das ist
der fundamentale unterschied zwischen
live zuschauern und on demand zuschauern
die durchschnittliche wiedergabe dauer
auf youtube ist teilweise unter 5
minuten manchmal klickten zuschauer nur
zehn sekunden drauf und es geht dann
direkt jetzt interessiert weg aber
dennoch zählen sie als klick dadurch
dass alle zuschauer genau in diesem
moment dasselbe sehen und auch einen
chat haben über den sie kommunizieren
können wird ein gemeinsames erlebnis für
alle kreiert und jeder das primär
engagiert man kann sich 1000 aktive
zuschauer also eher so ein bisschen im
konzert vorstellen bei dem die zuschauer
auch mal selbst geld in die hand nehmen
um ihren streamer zu unterstützen und
zusammen mit anderen lustigen moment zu
erschaffen und was das für einen riesen
unterschied macht finden wir jetzt
zusammen raus meint rich kanal existiert
bereits seit 2008 zehn ist aber relativ
inaktiv bis jetzt heutzutage ist live
stream echt eigentlich mega easy man
kann auf dem handy mit instagram stream
oder auch auftritt mit der trip ich
möchte aber im pc miralles einrichten
und dort stream und jacksons probieren
aber auch gaming und auch euch live mit
der man experimente mit nehmen auch
heute also wenn ihr jetzt gerade das
video hier seht bin ich ab 18 uhr live
auftritt also klickt gerne mal auf den
link in der beschreibung wenn ihr das
alles worum es geht mal als sehen
möchtet als aufnahme beziehungsweise
streaming programm plötzlich obs damit
kann man zwischen den kameraperspektiven
und bildschirmaufnahmen und kleiner face
camp hin und her schalten aber dieses
streaming interface muss jetzt auch
erstmal eingerichtet werden
streaming bitrate 6000 kilobit pro
sekunde auflösung 2.560 x 1.440 pixel
framerate 30 fps ja bitte nicht ich
mache keine 60 von prozessorauslastung
voreinstellungen bis hin zum codierer
wird jede kleinigkeit abgestimmt für das
perfekte bild und hier kann man jetzt
verschiedene quellen zu einer
sogenannten szene hinzufügen die hier
nenne jetzt am markt ganz kreativ
bildschirm und hier machen erstmal mit
bildschirmaufnahme sagt und zwar den
rechten moment wenn zum beispiel und
schon sind wir jetzt ein bildschirm dann
noch eine videoaufnahme und das waren
wir als fans können hier rechts oben in
die ecke dann kommt jetzt auch so ein
kleiner hübscher rande zu jetzt machen
wir noch eine zweite vollbildansicht und
da braucht man nur ein video
aufnahmegerät und zwar dass das man
schon haben und dann einmal vorbild
perfekt jetzt kann man zwischen diesen
beiden szenen einfach hin und
herschalten sogar per knopfdruck das hat
jetzt doch alles ein bisschen länger
gedauert als erwartet aber ich will
jetzt endlich anfangen zu stream in
einem meiner letzten videos habe ich ja
meine ganz eigene app entwickelt und da
wäre ich jetzt weiter machen und zwar
live
ok und 321 herausgekommen
ich finde jetzt eigentlich meine neuen
team im hintergrund war mein
geburtstagsgeschenk für meine freundin
und ganz vielen freunden von mir da ist
auch ständig oder sagen wir mal was ich
kann es mache dir deine umfrage worauf
er bock habt brisanz okay okay okay wir
machen neuen dino bruder als mannschaft
fertig vielleicht schafft dabei dass ich
bin eine weile online ich bin jetzt
profi streamer ja ich habe keine andere
wahl ausklang am start zu sein
das war normal und hat immer noch nicht
wieso man bis zu 1200 zuschauer dabei
zuschauen wie ich meine eigenen app
entwickelt extreme hier und da ja schon
länger auf switch und die hatte ich
bisher immer nur 50 bis maximal 100
zuschauer und das waren schon richtig
richtig krass und das habe ich ja auch
schon immer angekündigt natürlich aber
irgendwie das mit der app darauf hat
irgendwie blockiert aber trotzdem noch
mal ein paar neue sachen probieren das
team ging fünfeinhalb stunden
durchschnittlich fast 800 zuschauer
maximal 1265 insgesamt 23.000 juni cure
und 2866 einzelne menschen die im chat
geschrieben am etf und natürlich auf
4.000 neue follower auf switch das ist
krank und 26 neue tabs und da geht es
jetzt auch schon ans geld weil das ist
natürlich auch ein teil des videos und
das war schon echt übertrieben kreis
hier kamen nämlich einmal acht dollar 14
durch werbeeinnahmen 11 dollar vom
sogenannten cheering 31 euro durch die
nations und 65 euro von trips also
umgerechnet einfach 105 euro an einem
abend ich glaub das tauchen gut anfangen
oder her
dazu kommen dann noch die highlight
videos die ich auf meine zweite kanal
hochgeladen werden denn als gute
streamer macht man natürlich außer im
stream auch content für youtube und der
ist übrigens auffällig also wenn ihr die
woche verpasst habt und die einzelnen
highlights sehen möchte
dann schaut er gerne vorbei über den
link in der video beschreibt und jetzt
bin ich auf jeden fall gespannt wie sich
die woche noch sonst eclipse damit dass
darüber ja noch krasse wir uns richtig
spaß macht so netten aber natürlich vor
allem dass ich meine zuschauer wohl
fühlen und eine geile atmosphäre im
stream herrscht brauchen wir noch eigene
nachrichten und sounds die eingespielt
werden wenn zum beispiel jemand rheins
habt oder wenn jemand united oder
irgendwas einziges heftiges passiert
viele streamer haben hier ausgefeilte
animationen und soundeffekte die
wunderbar zum kanal konzept passen aber
da ich schlicht mag und das echt ein
bisschen aufwendiger ist als erwartet
und das team jetzt gestartet entscheide
ich mich für diese etwas schlichteren
einblendungen
und gedeiht und da sind wir auch schon
wieder live in 321 herzlich willkommen
zu diesem stream und wieder
kann man als zuschauer mitmachen bei
politik so zwei drei leute wer ist dabei
wir sind dabei die stelle mir vor wie
stark wir haben ja was haben wir unsere
flotte zu erzählen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir machten ein kleines spiel haben die
platzierung ich hier am ende hab wird
mit einem multiplikator multipliziert
und das muss ich dann quasi um eine
gemütliche alles gift
aktuell ist der multiplikator bei 13 ja
weil schon insgesamt 13 mal fünf selbst
ausgerichtet wurden danke wege sich ins
haar stecken jetzt ist der multiplikator
auf 15 ich hab hier so'n ding wir sind
bei 75 kräftigungs wie gifte man jetzt
75 ups da ich fünfter geworden bin let's
go 77 6 370 euro da kommen die grenats
groß tree misst zugegeben schon wirklich
etwas entspannter als ein video
aufwendig zu planen zu drehen und zu
schneiden aber über sechs stunden
durchgängig zu reden ist extrem ausland
in diesen sechs stunden darf ich
zumindest wenn ich möglichst wenige
zuschauer verlieren möchte nicht auf die
toilette gehen nichts essen und nicht
mal aufstehen um etwas zum trinken zu
holen und bin mehr oder weniger einen
stuhl gefesselt ich habe am schreibtisch
immer vier liter wasser für einen stream
aber wenn das team gegen 0 uhr 30 zu
ende ist fühle ich mich trotzdem durch
das ganze reden extrem dehydriert und
ausgebrannt und falle ins bett
ich bin jetzt gerade nach den
halbstunden aufbereitet und ich bin dann
wohl noch so fertig dass ich jetzt
direkt weiter schlafen muss jede sekunde
unterhaltung sein zu müssen und dabei
darauf zu achten wie das bild aussieht
was derzeit schreibt wie der ton pegel
ist und ob die fans kam vielleicht etwas
wichtiges verdeckt ist echt mental sehr
anstrengend
die woche vergeht jeden tag arbeite ich
circa zwei stunden am streaming
interface oder plane dinge für meine
streams und bin sechs stunden am stück
life aber wie stark wächst mein twitter
kanal dadurch wie entspannt war es nun
den beruf auszuführen der wohl als der
entspannteste gilt und wie viel geld
habe ich damit verdient kommen wir zum
resümee schlimmer sein ist echt mega
anstrengend aber die ersten ein bis zwei
stunden sind richtig entspannen und
machen auch echt mega rock macht danach
natürlich immer noch spaß ist aber auch
wirklich ein bisschen anstrengend kommen
wir zu den zahlen
das wachstum war nämlich auf jeden fall
am start mit durchschnittlich 2.500 30 9
verloren und 30.500 zuschauern pro tag
kommen wir zur kohle
dabei haben bezahlt deshalb 20 dollar
272 dollar
verschenktes sagt 350 dollar werbung 38
dollar
shearing also bis 52 dollar und du
nations also spenden 143 eur 81 1
gespielt alles in allem umgerechnet also
696 euro und 81 cent richtig aber das
war noch nicht alles denn auch die
youtube video streams entstanden sind
haben natürlich einkommen generiert und
liegt ein mal mehr und mal weniger gut
mit insgesamt 246 euro und 98 cent
diese videos also zum beispiel meine app
bekommt eine echte regierung sind
natürlich auch verlinkt 979 euro und 15
cent habe ich also in dieser woche
verdient ich sollte tricks klima werden
dass das natürlich nicht genau so
funktioniert hat ja wenn ich keine
reichweite von youtube weg gebracht
hätte das muss ich glaube ich nicht dazu
sagen auch heute 19 uhr bin ich live
auftritt also schauen sich gerne mal
vorbei zum stream findet ihr über den
link in der video beschreibung nächste
woche verbringe ich 24 langen stunden
gefesselt wenn ihr das nicht verpassen
und mich auf diese weise begleiten
möchte jetzt abonniert gerne in diesen
und wenn ihr keine herausstellte von den
videos schon bevor sie online kommen
sehen möchtest folgt mir gerne auf
instagram und dann sehen wir zunächst
mal wieder gut
[Musik]